- [Allison] Charlie is a beautiful
long-haired Persian Blue cat,
and he's really special.
Charlie's gonna get his
first lion cut today.
(lion roars)
("The Donk Main" by
Warner/Chappell Production Music)
He's never really had a haircut.
He has dreads, he's dirty and disgusting,
and it's time.
Um... (laughs)
No!
By the looks of it, I don't
think he's very excited.
Charlie!
How are you, little baby?
Oh my God! (laughs)
You're perfect!
He's not even looking at me, he's so mad.
(laughs)
He's a little rat boy!
Think it's really cute.
I think he's gonna be happy.
(laughing) He doesn't
seem that happy right now.
But I think he just wants to be freed.
Kind of was traumatized.
Yeah, I think this is a
good makeover for Charlie.
(laughing) Okay, I'll let
you go, I'll let you go.
Now, he's so small,
he's the smallest thing.
I thought he was like, this big boy cat.
Yeah, I'm so happy with it!
He looks so cute.